i want i want to talk about something
related to this trial too
here's what people need to understand
about gage gross kreutz and his attack
on kyle rittenhouse
we are all approaching this story about
kyle with hindsight from the moment the
story happened we had video footage of
that night and we all heard the first
thing we heard was that people had been
shot
so when we did this show with several of
the reporters on scene including one of
the key witnesses richie mcginnis we
already knew people had been shot and
killed
now think about what happened that night
however and what these individuals were
thinking as this event was going down
this is where the defense
nailed the star witness for the
prosecution like actually just destroy
one of the things they did destroy the
case from the state
they actually got him to testify he did
not have any reason to attack kyle
rittenhouse so again i'll stress this
point hopefully you know
some people i've tried to explain this
who have been confused but i think most
people are smart enough to get it
when we look at the story about kyle
rittenhouse it's with the benefit of
hindsight we know people had been shot
we know where they were shot we know how
it went down we know who is chasing kyle
we know kyle was putting out a fire and
then rosenbaum threatened him and chased
after him
gage grosskroitz testified
he was running after kyle rittenhouse he
really didn't like the word chasing
he asked kyle what happened kyle said
i'm going to get the police
gage gross kroitz testified he thought
kyle said i'm working with the police
his own words is what he said
he then said that kyle said i didn't do
anything
gage grosskroitz who is this he just
froze out from a key witness for the
state and one of people shot by kyle
redness was running alongside and
filming kyle rittenhouse
and testified he said kyle said i'm
working with the police that's what he
thought he said he didn't say that as he
thought he said
gross kroitz then turned back and ran
the other direction
when everyone started chasing after kyle
renthouse gross kreutz then turned
around and ran back towards kyle and as
seen on video pulling back his shirt and
drawing the pistol from his waistband
what's important here is at this point
the star witness testified that this
person said he was working with the
police
and because of that knowledge or
you know considering that knowledge he
was going to draw his pistol on this
individual
if someone tells you they're a cop or
working with the police would you pull a
gun on them he ran away first right
right now yeah he he so right now says
running he's running alongside him gross
croix runs back the other direction at
some point stops and turns around and
runs back what the defense got gross
croix to acknowledge is that he had not
seen a shooting
he had no evidence to believe that kylo
ren shot anybody he didn't know what
kylo ren was doing or why the only thing
he knew and this is his testimony was
that kyle rittenhouse was working with
the police
he decided to chase after cal
rittenhouse point a gun at him
it sounds like his intention was to kill
a cop
now
he was incorrect in the video footage
grosskroyd's testified in hindsight upon
watching the footage i realized he said
i'm going to get the police but he told
the police he thought reynolds was
working with them
if you thought someone was working with
the police
not an active shooter why would you
charge at them with your gun drone
this guy was not a hero he was not
trying to stop an active shooting he was
trying to kill someone he thought was a
police informant or working with the
police in some way
that strikes at the heart of what the
prosecution has been saying trying to
push this narrative that it was a bunch
of you know good samaritans trying to
stop an active shooter
the important thing here
just to just to reiterate
on the stand gross croits testified he
had no reason to believe rittenhouse was
an active shooter in fact he believed he
was working with the police
that's crazy
well all i can say is you really have
been following it oh that's like an
amazing amazing kind of um summary of
what i mean i that's that's really
really i mean everything about that is
is just so interesting and i think that
um
i know it's showing me what you know
this is so important because
it's gonna you have to hope that
a you know a legal process like this
when you've got such a high profile
um
and you know a situation that is so ripe
for exploitation and can go in such
horrible directions is going to be
conducted properly and fairly and
according to the law that you've got to
hope that the judge is doing a good job
i think the judge is doing a good job he
he's dismissed you know he's denied some
some emotions by the defense
he's been fair to uh the prosecution i
believe
and
the extremists the activists the
ideologues won't accept it well the
media is building a completely different
story here and if you're online if
you're in a certain echo chamber you're
getting a totally different perspective
of this criminal court case than you
would from any other perspective so
social media just
just doubling down on this narrative
that they're running
is truly something that is going to be
very important here because it may sway
uh the jury it may sway this entire
situation in in a way where there isn't
any justice and and steve just to
address your your point about the malice
and the media here uh we have to
understand when there was rioting the
mainstream media the corporate media
they were pouring fuel on the fire they
were peaceful protests they were calling
it yeah yeah they were calling them
peaceful protests they were showing
footage of george floyd dying over and
over and over again they were
psychologically programming and hyping
people up to go out there into the
streets and to riot and to create chaos
dozens of people died with the
mainstream media applauding and cheering
it on looking the other way when people
died uh so so when it comes to that
element
when it comes to them being that
malicious i mean look at wmds look at so
many times the mainstream media has been
malicious and
there's elements here that that that
they need to be called out for their
criminals i think you describe you know
what you're describing exactly is
exactly what happened i think that the
just in terms of like i cannot speak for
that that my sense however is that
all that um
narrative around that time
was driven by i mean it's actually part
of the whole
way in which the kind of woke ideology
has just infected so much of
of america's establishment institutions
and the media absolutely part of that
and so i think it was just this instant
reaction which was to say
the people that we see protesting
whether peacefully or violently um are
protesting in the name of racial justice
we have to be for racial justice we
can't be against racial justice and
therefore
anything that happens in in that that is
in in the name of racial justice we have
to support i support racial justice i
support real things to advance racial
justice like school reform whatever i
don't want to get into that now but um
they i think that's why that was the
motivation it was just this blanket
sense like we have this is our side we
have to be on this side so what does
that mean we totally amplify the um
peaceful protests part of it and we kind
of ignore the violent part of it i kind
of disagree with you because if there
was a person of color or a woman
speaking out against the violence or the
insanity they would viciously attack
them ruthlessly in the most unfair ways
imaginable they would send hate mobs
against them on the line and and they
would they would use them as an example
of what you're not supposed to think
what you're not supposed to say and it
didn't matter if they were black if they
were white they went after them if they
countered the agenda and the narrative
so the social justice warrior aspect is
not something that that i believe they
truly believe in i think they believe in
power and i think they will do anything
it's a good point i think that they okay
let's be more precise so not like real
racial justice it's the virtue signaling
about racial justice that's actually
what what what what what what is
important to them and that's why they
can't stand it when you have for example
you know
black conservatives making you know i i
i i think that is the thing they hate
the most because it totally undermines
the foundations of the new ideology
that's infected them which is this
wokism and so when you have people
making really smart arguments about how
which i totally agree and i've given a
platform to which is to say look if we
really want to advance you know if we
want to sort of fight racial um
racial racially um clear gaps on uh
wealth or income inequality poverty
school then you know there's real
policies you can advance to achieve that
they happen to typically be conservative
policies and the evidence shows that but
that's not an argument they want to have
they don't if they lose it thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you